dea
方向時代に僕は映画館のバイトをしていたある日昼休みを募りの中華レストラン
スーパー茶犬で過ごした後で映画館に戻り案内係をしていると中年男が2人
やってきた一人はどの強そうの眼鏡をかけ i love new york の
デザインをもじった i love microsoft の t シャツを着た
1980年代のた
基準で言えばかっこいい音に入るだろうけれど今では時代遅れとしか言いようがない
感じの男だった
もう一人はといえば同大この胸筋今にも折れの t シャツはちきれそうだろう
子供用の m サイズですからねというプロのボディビルダーにはなれなかったけど
まだ週2回ジムに通っているでそういう雰囲気を醸し出そうと子だった
右側の5羽目ですチケットを切って彼らにを足すときふと気が付いたチケットが3枚
あったのだ
どうもーと3枚のチケットを受け取った2人を同時に入ってスクリーンの方へ歩き出し
た
バルーンと僕は言ったが彼らが振り返らなかったあのすいません
大声で言ってみると彼だワンんな何事もなかったかのようにこちらにゆっくりと
向き直った
チケット3枚あるんですけどそうだねキン肉マンが当然のようにじゃあ1枚食べておく
ねっ
ここ関西じゃないから他に誰かいらっしゃるんですか
マイクロソフトラブが笑みを浮かべたそのうちわかるや
はいクラシックフレーバーキン肉マンが丁寧に発音しながらゆっくりとそういった
クラシックフレーバーですかそう
キン肉マンがまたゆっくりといった暮らし
9フレーバーさっきつまりの中華レストランで食べた餃子ん楽にヤバイものが入ってい
たかもしれないとその時僕は反射的に思ったクラシック触れ
レイバーって言うんですかプラスチックフレーバーが来たら案内してやってくれ
彼の分もちゃんと払ったんでクラシックフレーバーってその方の名前なんですね by
頃ソフトラードがメガネをかけなおし
再び笑みを浮かべたそのうちわかりや僕はに3度の2期した
けど男たちは消えなかった失礼です彼はクラシックフレーバーさんを見分ける方法を
教えていただけますか
見分ける必要はない
すごいかですがそういえばの餃子確か変な臭いをしたんだろうなぁと思いながら
わかりましたではどうぞごゆっくりと床が答えたとしてあの二人のただの錯覚だったと
いうことにしてトイレに行って顔を洗った
右側の2番目は pi 顔の7番目トイレから戻っていつもと同じように案内係をして
いるとやがて彼は行ってきた
な身長推定2m 外は冷たい雨が降っているというのに
サンダルと水着とアロハシャツに麦わら同市まるでハワイのビーチから直接行ってきた
ような格好した20代後半とおぼしきニヤニヤ顔の男を彼は僕の目の前で達どもって家
に大きなサングラスを取り出してゆっくりとパケた
いらっしゃいません男はニヤニヤしながら鼻を鳴らした
もしかして僕は無意識に唇を動かしてたん
彼は再びニヤリと笑ったクラシックフレーバーさんですか
分
右側の5羽目ですね
me